uh here's what I gotta say to y'all go
to iTunes buy the song give me the
dollar
one down one purchase for a dollar
counts as 150 streams if he gets I think
he needs 150 million streams and looks
like he's already got 30 plus 147 000
downloads so multiply that by 150. if he
gets 1 million downloads he will be
platinum let's let's let's do what we
can I think I think rich men north of
Richmond should be platinum I'll tell
you why I'm not a country guy never been
a big country guy but anything that
advances independent culture challenging
the corporate machine pushing back on
Hollywood and these sick record labels
and the entertainment industry
needs to succeed and that's why I mean
just seeing the success of this song
the fares of Bud Light failures of
Target the success of sound of Freedom
ladies and gentlemen this is changing
the culture and winning the culture war
and they know it